so we are
on our way to New Orleans I don't
remember what I'm supposed to be doing
there you but tariffs undone asked me to
come out to do this show I don't know
what it exactly
I don't any pajamas but your lease place
up and wanted to go for the longest time
specifically because I love cajun food
and you guys know I make a mean ask up
but when I'm pretty
compared to the stuff out there so I'm
trying to see how
Gators crocodiles I got bills and
titties stepping out of the airport kind
of find out how humid this place is
that's the interest in Europe in an
air-conditioned area and the moment you
walk out it's like damn hot Indian
diaper I don't know how I'm gonna handle
that did you lie I tend to get heat
rashes in humid weather if you don't
know what a heat rashes is basically a
[ __ ] diaper rash all over your body
[Music]
you
[Music]
but what the [ __ ] oh yes I thought I
didn't have a soul per se in two minutes
I am moist I'm incredibly moist you know
a lot of you don't even like that word
out there but I [ __ ] moist I kind of
just hop locked my [ __ ] moisture up
[Music]
so this is a hotel I believe it's called
the Mirage didn't really check it out
but we got here for the show I saw a lot
of crabbing equipment out there but I've
been on a plane for about four hours so
you know we got to get in that Korean
stretch now if you haven't seen this
before it's simple you start with
getting your kneecaps pack you start
getting the devotee now kind of get
those hips you want swing got my stretch
on this is MTV Cribs style check it out
we got these under glow lights under the
bed ball is life we got these pegs right
here so you can hang your [ __ ]
ballers life kind of TV made by LG
life's good and of course we got this
sham wild type of fabric for the blanket
he takes out wet myself
now on the way here oh my god have a
Pyrrhic on the way here it was really
fun because we had a we had a
conversation with our uber driver she
was super sweet kind of a very talkative
I'm not a lot of people in LA where they
kind of tend to uh either talk about
what they're doing how much money they
make in the stage she was talking about
the city how much she loves it and and
you know like fun interesting facts
which I really appreciate but if
everybody in New Orleans is like certain
I think I'm having a good time
oh and they gave us three drinks when we
came here - the guy was super nice
everybody seems to be super nice I hope
it's not just like this small area here
but hospitable so this is like the
dinner portion of what we're about to do
I don't know what this restaurant is
known for I don't know if it's good I
just know that's gonna be oh and there's
a menu right there being bang Val she's
about being about business it seems a
little fancy it's a little bit more
upscale I think this is going to be like
that Cajun food this has a little bit of
a chef's twist to it as you can see the
menu has no pictures
so that's fancy I don't know if I'm
gonna get my New Orleans experience here
but you know it's a good way to start
off the meal we have a whole night ahead
of us a couple of drinks some more food
it's about to get crazy see you
no love
Oh
I don't know what I was talking to the
hostess up there so she gave me all the
recommendations I mean she suggested the
jerk corn aioli with crispy chicken
because they just put it on the menu
because it was popular and then she said
for sure the cold smoked tuna tartare
and then either the duo of beef the
curried goat which would you mentioned
and the pic of pasta I like
I have to one of the things I hate the
most is like going to dinner and you
know when you'll kind of expect a great
meal and you have to pay for it if it
tastes bad it's like you ruin my whole
night I hate it these are buttermilk
biscuits either this whole spiel about
it there's something about baking in
there - I think it's buttermilk biscuits
with Bacon's and child from what I
remember I'm a huge biscuit fan one of
my favourite biscuits of all time is
some Church's Chicken you all know about
Church's Chicken that's that good [ __ ]
warm and chives
I'm good
[Music]
oh look there's like bacon fat mark as
awesome this is a breaded deep-fried pig
ears yeah figure try it I mean I'll try
anything I like that you're not Asian
for the blood especially bigger there's
like very cartilaginous depending on how
is prepared so this because it's defined
I know what it is but it kind of just
tastes like kind of like a hardened
piece of like pig fat but it's better
than the deep-fried everything ready
part is great this is the deep-fried
dirty rice ah Don Cheney balls going a
little testicle should be delicious
like cheese's I'd gotten 20 balls are
really good deep-fried super hot inside
Barry this is the coke cut the crunchy
hope that Taj is like a sea snail you
know that thing that you see when people
are lost in the island and they blow
into that [ __ ] that's a concert
how do you feel about it I don't know
I'm not either right now I heart good
though
very hot I really takes the punch but
then when you defy anything that with
cheese it's pretty good
what did I first meet you it was a while
ago was it at the batch a video Shiva
was it before that which you it was like
when bets just started it was like
before he was really doing fine yeah for
the blinds video or the remarkable
vagina video haha you know what that
video you were seeing up on stage Oh
another first time I ever like know what
it is I've known of you fear so much
longer and like watched your content so
I feel like I've known your oh ok ok
yeah that's only person we actually met
okay no you're like YouTube friends
and I think you've been friends for a
longer but okay I think that's what it
was yeah yeah yeah I was like oh [ __ ] so
let's talk about what we got here for
the first course we got the function
actually targets are so when you guys
hear something against coal smoke it's
exactly what it is you're gonna get that
smoky flavor but you're not going to get
the product cook by a hot smoke so when
you think about a hotdog you thinking
about stuff like when you compress cater
to
smoked meats and stuff like that this is
under cold smoke so you can see the
flesh is still very apparently very tuna
but you get that nice deep flavor from
that the cilantro on that I didn't see
that's it tastes a lot more Asian than I
expected so there's onions in there
there's an avocado puree and I think
that's crappy on top as well probably
one of the better to the talked I've
ever met
Cheers
[Music]
right
nice
it tastes very Asian I didn't expect
that yeah
[Music]
right
okay so I was right from the first
tasting this is a flattened out banana
I was thinking it might be a plantain
but it was it's a flattened out banana
so usually when you go to these
restaurants do a tuna tartare they
always give you some type of vessel to
eat with it whether it's like a deep
fried plantain chip it could be a
Tarleton it can be crackers saltines
whenever you have it but they did
something a little different it's like
black sesame is in the banana this is a
bite of the hamachi coconut curry with
pickled mango and trout roe
I love hamachi by the way very buttery
here we go that's good I wonder if the
Shepherd has liked Caribbean influences
because you taste a lot of life that is
like yeah coconut curry that's very
Caribbean and that's on point a lot of
people out there might be a little
daunted when you guys see like fish roe
but this picture fish was another type
of seasoning like there's like this
salty little ocean ball and when you
bite into it it kind of adds like a
solidity to the to the good of this that
you're having and it really kind of
brings it up another loss so the little
assault any food based is what I'm
saying
yeah that was out of the park I love it
so it's a Wednesday night I met it I'm
at a table filled ribbon what can I say
I'm not single so it doesn't mean
anything to me Muriel I love you these
women they're not even interested in
tell you right now if I was single
though everybody at this table will be
rejecting me at this moment
here we have a duel big duo meeting two
types of beef on the plate this looks
like a tender one piece I don't know
what that is it looks like it's braised
of some sort
we have peas carrots in the carrot puree
with a sauce on top of that so just like
attending class but I'm gonna try this
out perfect medium rare super tender
seasoned really well
it's a good piece of beef that's
definitely a demi-glace sauce on that it
tastes like braised short rib delicious
piece is very similar for dish
[Music]
No
this expects to
it makes me lose my appetite here let's
switch you can have this I think it has
a huge fear of seafood and he thought he
was brave enough to go ahead and try
this out
it almost threw up so I gave him my duel
beef but now I'm eating his lobster
lobster pasta so as a really good
flavorful tomato sauce it's very rustic
you can still see the the pieces of
garlic that was sliced in there it
wasn't minced or just dissolved into the
sauce it has a really strong seafood
flavor which I personally love it
doesn't so much and then on top of that
has very generous big chunks of lobster
that's how it's supposed to be so when
you guys go eat Italian food doesn't
huge difference and when you get
packaged pasta and fresh pasta way
different the texture is way better so
when you have al dente pressingly pasta
it kinda has like a very spongy
I still have like that chewy al dente
mouthfeel but it's definitely a little
more tender fresh pasta - by the way
absorbs a lot more flavor so whatever
sauce that fresh pastas in is can absorb
that flavor so you could taste the
lobster you could taste the tomato sauce
and having a little bit of the heat -
which I like to as well now we have the
finale which is going to be dessert this
is a chocolate cake of some sort with
some kind of chocolate soup it obviously
looks like diarrhea and pus but I don't
know that's somewhat appetizing we have
these little charcoal briquettes on the
side and some dirt this makes me feel
weird they kind of you know that triple
phobia thing where you see dots and this
makes me feel like that so excuse me as
I do that to it I'm not that big of a
dessert guy but we want to give it a go
it's not overly sweet it's still very
decadent but it's not something that's
put up blasting with a lot of sugar it's
not pulling the sweet I enjoyed this a
lot and then you have like the mango
over there to kind of just add that
little bit of brightness towards the end
because you like that really deep
chocolate that's bomb
[Music]
so we just finished with our meal and
compared Lipan that's Creole French for
you uncultured brutes like I knew that
[ __ ] before I ask the hostess the food
was amazing probably the best thing that
I had here had definitely had to be the
dessert I'm not that big of a chocolate
fan but if the Executive Chef or whoever
created that dish can take someone like
me who doesn't like the maining great in
a dish and maybe walk away with a smile
and I think that chef did a great job
with that this place is just the the
beginning of my culinary experience here
my culinary journey that sounds so
[ __ ] douchey it's my experience of
meeting some bomb-ass food here there
you go that's more Davis so like but New
Orleans we're kicking it off right man
it's about to be popping how do you how
do you pronounce the name of the
restaurant
compare the fun come compare LaVon come
I'm here come on compare look Han
compare Lacan okay thank you